alors ça c'est le poids je donne
l'illusion là il reste même pas grand
chose dedans voir que l'huile c'est pour
donner l'illusion que notre frigo n'est
pas vide même quand il ya plus grand
chose dedans en fait
c'est pour se rassurer je viens d'avoir
40 7 ans je suis bénéficiaire du rsa
ma fille est née à 18 ans et demi et mon
fils va voir 14 je suis depuis toujours
mère célibataire de deux enfants j'ai eu
souvent des réflexions dans le passé
avec les aimes tu vis mieux qu'un
smicard mec t'as pas besoin des deux tu
t'en sors très bien si j'ai été filmée h
24 tout ce que je dois déployés à titre
personnel pour tout le temps garder la
tête de l'eau et que ont une vie qui
soit dans une certaine forme de
normalité sans boulot monstre
[Applaudissements]
la contribution financière demandée 4
euros
la base c'est le lait l'huile le sucre
le café un peu de fruits et légumes en
fonction de ce qu'ils on va avoir des
céréales que ya pas mal de concerts
il agrémente par exemple ça sympathique
cela vous avez décroître
voilà et les légumes c'est un peu près
fixes sur la saison ça par exemple c'est
quelque chose qui sont en plus qui est
variable en fonction des saisons
un salut comme ça je pense que j'en
aurai pour
60 euros à peu près surtout qu'il ya des
produits qui sont produits localement
donc ça représenterait que je ne
pourrais pas mettre d'essence dans la
voiture ça représenterait que comme mes
enfants nous en renouveler la trousse ou
une activité qui vient se greffer par
l'école je pourrais pas la payer voilà
ça représenterait que le reste à vivre
ne partirai que dans la nourriture si
j'avais pas l'aide des associations
une fois par mois voilà on fait le gros
comme ça et puis après moi je complète à
côté avec l'épicerie voilà un typique un
panier garni donc ça c'est le petit plus
c'est ce qui permet aussi
bas aux enfants de ne pas marquer de
différences spécifiques par rapport aux
autres voilà
oui là c'est l'entrepôt nous fait ou on
fait les collègues pour distribuer dans
les foyers en fait voilà et la g1 a
semaine prochaine
secours populaire moi je sais que même
quand je m'en serais sorti je
continuerai à aider d'une façon ou d'une
autre
grâce au secours populaire on a pu
partir à des endroits où on serait
jamais partie mais après souvent aussi
ils nous offrent des places aux élites
pour aller voir des humoristes pour
aller voir des spectacles il y as
nourrit remis aux six nourrir autrement
et ça serait que de ce côté là ils sont
vraiment géniaux fait plein de choses
aussi pour montrer à mes enfants et à
d'autres personnes on peut quand même
avancé malgré tout ça il ya beaucoup de
gens aussi qui mirent à tulle gagnerait
à acheter les produits en gros rush est
d'accord c'est plus avantagés d'acheter
des produits en gros mais le seul
problème c'est que quand vous avez que
20 euros par semaine vous pouvez pas
vous permettre d'acheter 50 rouleaux de
papier qui sont moins chers certes mais
les 20 euros par semaine ne parte que
dans le papier mais on mange pas quand
le papier toilette chez nous
nous arrivons à l'essence mon budget à
la semaine d'essence est de 20 euros est
cueilli d'inflation pas sur les sens ce
sera quand même 20 euros
[Musique]
lilith
quoi qu'il arrive ça doit durer une
semaine
alors là on va à l'épicerie solidaire
qui est juste à côté de chez moi
[Applaudissements]
l'homme produit comme ça en commerce et
en pharmacie sociaux entre 15 et 20
euros là il est à 3 euros par exemple en
dehors de cette épicerie j'aurais pas
accès au bio ou alors si mais alors je
fais car pas dans la semaine pour manger
bio en fait dans ma famille notamment
mon papa qui n'habitent pas dans ce
département et qui adore le pain
d'épicés dans ces genres de produits que
je peux lui revenu parce que 0,81 noun
commerce au centre ville je le paierai
entre 5 et 10 euros par exemple donc ça
permet aussi de ne pas être coupure on
va dire social avec les gens qui des
fois nous inviter ou je me suis retrouvé
souvent à dire nous parce que j'arrivais
leymarie dès que j'ai horreur de ça
d'ici là
voilà on perd l'impression d'avoir fait
des courses pas possible
je suis vraiment entrer dans le
dispositif rsa bain depuis la naissance
de ma première fille donc ça va faire à
peu près vingtaine d'années et il ya eu
des périodes où je travaillais des
périodes de jeu ne consacrait plus
problématique de mes enfants qui m'ont
attribué un droit au logement ils m'ont
attribué un droit au rsa ça fait à peu
près 1100 euros déduction faite après de
cet appel qui part au bailleur il me
reste 840 euros sur mon compte alors
avec ses 840 euros je paye 206 euros 39
de loyer à cela se rajoute
tout ce qui est gaz électricité il me
reste un peu près entre 150 et 200 euros
selon les mois et c'est là dedans que
vient mais varrault d'essence mais
complément l'épicerie voilà et après ben
on jongle vraiment la chose que je veux
faire passer par rapport à tout ça c'est
que dans toute chose il ya du bon et du
moins bon et tout ce parcours m'a permis
de me dire que on pouvait y arriver
quelle que soit sa situation
le rsa c'est une aide et on a une chance
extrême de l'avoir dans notre pays
maintenant ça règle pas tout non ça aide
comme son nom explique maintenant il
faut déployer des ressources
personnelles pour vivre sinon c'est sûr